[MUSIC PLAYING]
NAOMI SEYFER: Hi.
Thanks, everyone, for coming.
I'd also like to take a moment
to thank the back of the house.
They've been doing a wonderful
job with this conference,
and round of applause for them.
[APPLAUSE]
MYLES BORINS: One more
group to quickly thank.
As you'll notice, at
the side over here
we've got live
transcriptions happening.
That's a person who's
doing a great job
and trying to help make
this event more inclusive.
So a quick one for them as well.
[APPLAUSE]
NAOMI SEYFER: And I know
this is the last session
before the concert.
You're all tired and/or
excited for the concert.
So we'll-- well, with that,
I'd like to first take a moment
to introduce my
compatriot, Myles Borins.
He's a developer
advocate on Google Cloud.
He's also a longstanding
member of the Node.js community
and, in fact, the director of
the Node.js Technical Steering
Committee.
Fun fact about him
is the first time
he used Node was for
an art installation,
so he's also an
artist and a musician.
MYLES BORINS: It's true.
Here we have Naomi Seyer.
Naomi's a senior software
engineer on Serverless,
working on Cloud Run.
How many of you in the audience
have heard of Cloud Run before?
By the end of this presentation
it will be all the hands,
and I'm excited about that.
Naomi's also working on the
Knative client working group,
is the lead of that team.
You'll hear a little bit
more about that project
as well as we get into the talk.
Naomi is a language
polyglot, loves
every single language but
not necessarily all of them
equally.
Naomi, back to you.
NAOMI SEYFER: So this
talk is about serverless.
What is even serverless?
It's a buzzword that you
may have been hearing.
It's hot in the cloud
compute sphere these days.
Our conception of it is
kind of a catch-all term.
It has a few components that if
a compute product meets them,
we consider it under the
umbrella term of serverless.
The first of those
is that you don't
have to worry about
infrastructure and management.
You might hear me
repeat this "you
don't have to worry about"
phrase pretty often.
"You don't have
to worry about" is
kind of the theme of serverless.
So first, you don't have to
worry about infrastructure
management.
No VM provisioning,
no metal provisioning,
no bare metal provisioning.
Your scaling is going
to be automatic,
and it will scale up and
down as your needs require.
Another element of it is that
your security is fully managed.
You don't have to worry about
some kernel vulnerability
or, for a lot of the products,
some library vulnerability
happening.
All of those are updated
behind the scenes
so you don't have
to worry about it.
And you also don't have to
worry about paying for resources
that you're not using.
The products that we
consider serverless,
you pay only for what you use.
You pay only for the CPU
and memory and requests
that you're using.
And when nobody is using the
service, it scales down to zero
and you don't pay
anything for that.
So in this talk, we'll talk you
through the three serverless
compute options that
Google Cloud has--
Cloud Functions, App
Engine, and Cloud Run--
and when you might want
to use each of them,
because they each have their
strengths and weaknesses.
These options lie along the
spectrum of serverless, which
is part of kind of a larger
spectrum of computation, where
at one end you just
write a tiny bit of code
and you send it to a server
and it runs it for you,
like Google Cloud Functions,
and on the other end of that you
have requisitioning blade
servers to go put in your data
center.
But we won't talk about that
because that's not serverless.
So we'll talk about the spectrum
of serverless compute, where
at one end you have more ease
of use and at the other end
you have more control, though
they're all with good control
and good ease of use.
So what will we build?
MYLES BORINS: What we
ended up collaborating on
is a URL link
shortening service.
It's built entirely
servicely on an architecture
that we'll show you momentarily.
But perhaps the first thing
that we should show you
is the product itself.
So I'm going to come over here
and get onto the demo machine
here.
And we're going to
go to min.kni.sh.
Small kni.sh.
And we can see
the basic UI here.
This has been built
with Material for Web.
We can click on the URL here.
And let's make a
shortlink for google.com.
We'll submit that shortlink.
And get this minified
link almost right away.
So we can see that it has
a little [INAUDIBLE] here
that we've generated and
it takes us to google.com.
We could similarly go here
and create the shortlink
and give it a specific
shortlink like "goog."
Submit and wait.
And oh, we got a 409 that
the shortlink already exists
and go somewhere else.
And we've got this
really fun cow
that's giving us a little
fortune as part of our 404
page.
We'll similarly get
errors if we try
to go for shortlinks
that don't exist
or if we try to go to
routes that don't exist,
with the appropriate errors.
And get different
fortunes each time.
So now if we move back
to the presentation
we can talk a little bit
more about the architecture
that we're working with.
So when you come
in, you're going
to be using a front end that's
been built with Express,
and it's run on
Google App Engine.
That's routing all
of the requests that
are coming from the browser.
Then, depending on the
endpoint that you're hitting,
we're either
creating a shortlink
or getting a
shortlink, and we're
using a Cloud function to make
calls to the database there.
And for any of the errors,
we're actually hitting Cloud Run
because we've got some
serverless bash going,
but we'll show you
that a bit later.
One of the things that I really
love about this architecture
is that we've managed to sandbox
the access to the database
from the front-end application.
Through IAM rules, we
can even limit the access
to the database altogether so
that it's only the function
service accounts
that can call it.
And we're also making
sure that we're
sanitizing the data before
it ever gets to the database.
So there's no way
from that front end
to directly access
the database at all.
Now the first
product that we want
to dig into a little bit
more is Cloud Functions.
Naomi, would you like to tell
us a little bit more about it?
NAOMI SEYFER: So
in Cloud Functions,
you write code to do one thing.
You don't have to worry
about your request plumbing.
That's handled by the Cloud
Functions framework for you.
And your dependencies are
resolved in the cloud,
so you don't worry about
dependency management.
You don't worry about
request plumbing.
And you can set
your functions up
to trigger by a
variety of things.
So you can set them up to
trigger by someone creating
an object in a storage bucket.
You can set them up to
trigger by someone publishing
something to a
cloud pub/sub topic,
or by HTTP requests
from the outside,
or from your cloud, which
is what we've done here.
And you've got no worries
about concurrency.
You only have one
threat of execution
in your Cloud Function at once.
So it's really
the easiest to use
of our serverless
compute environments.
At the same time,
in Cloud Functions
your language selection is
a little bit more limited.
We've only got Node, Python,
and Go for that right now.
And you have to code in
a way that's specifically
intended for Cloud Function.
So if you've got a larger
Express.js or Django web
app that you want to
bring into serverless,
Cloud Functions might not
be your choice for that.
That would need
serious refactoring
to work in Cloud Functions.
And the flip side of not
worrying about concurrency
is you don't have
access to concurrency.
You can't say give me a hundred
requests that run at once,
I can run a hundred threads.
You're limited to one
request at once per instance.
So Myles will walk you through
some of the Cloud Functions
we've got.
MYLES BORINS: So
the first function
that we created was
createShortlink.
This is the function
that we're going
to call to make new shortlinks
or, alternatively, fail
if it doesn't work.
It takes a URL and a
shortlink as a parameter
and it stores it
in the database.
The next function that we
created was getShortlink.
It takes a shortlink
as a parameter,
and then it gives
you back the URL
itself that you're
supposed to go to.
So let's take a look
at this turtle here
and what they're
asking us to do.
It's telling us
to go to the demo,
and I always listen to
what turtles tell me to do.
So here we're in the
Cloud console again,
and this is the landing
page for functions.
We've got the
createShortlink function
and the getURL function.
Let's dig into the
create URL function
and see what's going on here.
The first thing
that we'll notice
is we've got some really
great insight into the usage.
We can see the most
recent invocation.
That was the demo that I
just showed you earlier.
We can see the usage
over the last 30 days,
and we can see the day
that I sent this service
to all my friends
to try to break it
before I used it onstage.
We also get access to
a couple other things.
We have the trigger
itself right here,
so we can click this link.
And you can see we get
an error, because we
haven't sent the right request.
We can see the source code as
well, by clicking on Source.
If we look at
index.js here, we can
see there's a couple
helper functions
that we've made for
interacting with the database.
And here you can
see the general way
in which we create functions.
I'm exporting the function
with the name of what
my service will be
called, and that export
is an asynchronous function.
This will allow me to
use the awake keyword.
I don't know-- how
many people here
are familiar with
JavaScript and async/await?
Oh, very cool!
I think it's made the language
infinitely better to work with.
And a really cool thing
with Cloud Functions
is you can export
async functions, which
makes it far simpler to start
doing some asynchronous stuff.
You get a request and a
response for an HTP function
and it's more or less the exact
same contract as an Express app
if you're used to using Express.
So here we have a couple
different things that
we're doing to make sure that
we've gotten a good request
and sending proper
warnings when we haven't.
And then when we actually make
the call to the database here,
we can send the right
information if the result was
successful and
warn if it wasn't.
Now we also, in the
Cloud Functions thing
here, have the ability of
testing the function itself.
So we can go ahead and give
the long link to google.com
and try to test that function
and see what happens.
And it gave us back a
warning that we should also
include the shortlink.
So let's do that
right now, and we'll
give it the short link google.
And we can test the
function, and it successfully
returned the shortlink, which
means that the service worked.
So if we go back really
quickly to getURL.
And we can jump
right to testing it.
We can call getURL with
the shortlink google.
We can test the
function, and we can
see that we got back
the URL that we created.
One of the things you will
notice with this service
is that we're not baking
in any of the hostnames.
So what's really cool
about this is this service
can sit on top of any
number of different URLs,
and the database could
even transfer around
for other services.
So that's it to show right
now for the functions.
If we go back to the
slide deck, we're
going to look at the next
technology that we used,
which was App Engine, which
we used for the front end.
And Naomi will walk us through
a little bit about App Engine
and why you might want to
use that specific product.
NAOMI SEYFER: Whereas
Functions was one operation
and you're done--
you just do one function,
return the response to that,
and done--
in App Engine you
write a service
that can deal with
a variety of paths
and can do a variety
of related operations.
You still have a lot of
the benefits of functions,
like the automatic security,
patching of libraries.
The libraries are still
resolved in the cloud.
But you have a few more
language runtimes available.
We have Java, Python,
Go, PHP, and Node.
And you can bring your
own web application
framework or mobile back-end
application framework.
If you want to write in Django,
you can write in Django, Flask,
you can write in Flask.
Can you tell that I'm a
Python person rather than
a Node person, mostly?
And you can have the
idiomatic language environment
to what you're used to.
So you write the
code that you're
used to deploying to any
other kind of situation.
You write that.
You send the code up
to us in the cloud.
We resolve the
dependencies for you
in a language-idiomatic way,
and we make your code run,
and we scale it automatically,
and do the serverless thing
for you in all the ways that
I described serverless before.
Myles will describe
the front end
that we wrote in App Engine.
MYLES BORINS: So we have a
couple of different routes
that we're handling in App
Engine with the Express app
that we built. The first
route is just slash.
It's what happens at the
root, and for that we serve
a form for a new shortlink.
The next route that we
have is a post to /link.
This is the endpoint
that we post
to to create new
shortlinks that will then
proxy that request
to the Cloud Function
that I was showing earlier.
Finally, we have a
post to get shortlink.
This is very similar to
just get on the root,
except we catch any other
words that are there
to be used as a parameter
for figuring out,
hey, what shortlink
are we asking for.
And then we serve the
appropriate redirect
for the browser.
So I think the turtle's
telling us it's time
to show off a demo again.
So here we're in the
App Engine console.
And if you are trying to
figure out how to get it,
if you click the
Navigation menu,
here you can see
that we've pinned it.
But if you just were to scroll
down on the Products page
to Compute, it's right in there,
and you can click on App Engine
and then click on Dashboard
to get to the page
that I'm on right now.
We can see the requests
that have come through,
and take a look at them.
We can see services.
We have one default service
that's deployed right now,
but you can deploy
multiple services,
multiple independent
App Engine instances all
in the same project.
You're not limited to one.
We have various versions.
These are all the
different versions
that we've deployed
of this application.
As you can see, we've made
some changes over time.
One of the things that
I really love about this
is the traffic allocation
bit that you can see here.
It makes it really intuitive
and straightforward,
with a couple clicks
to split traffic
across a couple
different instances.
One time where I find this
extremely useful is hey,
we've made a small
change and we're not 100%
whether or not this is
going to break some people.
You can do a new version,
not automatically deploy
its production, and just
write about maybe 10% or 5%
of traffic to that service.
You can even run that
service with special headers
in the logger so it's easier
to see exactly what's going on
and progressively roll out
that service over time,
instead of just transitioning
all the traffic at once.
You'll be able to see there's
a handful of other things
in the menu here.
We're not going to dig too
much into those right now.
But I would say the
cron jobs are also
one of my favorite things,
and Cloud Scheduler
is other product
you can look into.
But let's take a look at the
code that we're using here.
In our front-end
service here we have--
it's a package JSON.
It's a idiomatic Node.js app.
We have a handful of
different dependencies, not
many dev dependencies.
The one main thing
that you definitely
need when you're doing
things with App Engine
is the app.yaml file.
This runtime line right here
is actually the only thing
that you need to include
to get something deployed.
And we're saying which
runtime we're using.
These handlers that
you see below here
are what we're using to
specify the static content.
So during the
deployment, everything
that's in /stylesheets and
/scripts and /.* are going
to be cached by a
CDN at the edge.
We know that all those
assets are static,
so by creating these
handlers, App Engine smartly
knows how to cache that.
And then we have app.js
here, which is the main entry
point into our application.
We've got a little bit
of song and dance here.
The code is available online.
We'll give you a link at
the end of the presentation.
But the two biggest
things to check out here
are these two bits right here.
And this is idiomatic
express for saying, hey, here
are particular routes, and when
we hit those routes let's use
these particular middlewares.
And you'll notice that we have
two different routes that we're
doing, one being the
index route that's
handling both the case
of hitting slash as well
as hitting any of
the parameters,
and then link, which is the
endpoint that we're posting
to to create a new link.
So one of the things that I
wanted to show really quickly
was how we can quickly update
and redeploy the application.
So we're in the
front-end app now.
If we go here in the front end
and we take a look at our view,
and we have index.pug here.
And you can see that
this is where we get
that header for URL Shortener.
Well, let's just change
that to Hello IO.
And we're going to save that.
We're going to see
the Git status.
We can see the diff.
By the way, what
we're using right now
is called the Cloud Shell.
And we're also using
the Cloud Editor.
This is all built right
into Google Cloud.
We're changing this all live
on the stage with a Chromebook.
You can do this on the road
with pretty much anything that
has a keyboard and a browser.
And if you're in Cloud
Source Repositories, which
is where I was
showing this for, it
allows you to push Git
repositories right to cloud.
You can literally click this
button right here, Edit Code,
and that's going to open up
this Cloud Shell environment
that you see me working in.
So we've now changed
Hello IO, and we're
going to run gcloud app deploy.
And it's going to say, hey,
you sure you want to do this?
I'm pretty sure I want to do.
And no such component?
Oh, I know what's going on here.
We need to just npm
install really quickly.
Thank you for being
patient with me.
This is what happens when you
try to do things onstage live.
How many people have
done live demos before?
OK.
Hold on.
Keep your hands up for a second.
Lower your hand if you've
ever had a live demo not
blow up in your face.
[LAUGHS]
So we're almost done here.
We're just about done.
I'm doing a really
good job of stalling.
And now we'll gcloud app deploy.
We'll say yes.
The reason why that
happened is because I'm
doing some fancy thing
with symbolic links.
I should have learned the
lesson about symbolic links
at sometime in the
past, but I didn't.
So let's just go back.
I want to show you one
more thing in App Engine
while that's deploying
that I didn't show you.
Here in the settings,
you'll notice
when we were on the site
that we're at min.kin.sh,
not at like an App
Engine-specific site.
App Engine supports
custom domains.
So you'll notice here that
I've created a custom domain.
It gives me all of
the rules to set up.
I just put that
into my DNS settings
and now that domain will always
forward to the App Engine
instance.
App Engine will also provision
all of the SSL certificates
for you.
So as you noticed, we were
doing everything at HTTPS,
and I believe if I
just go to HTTP-- oh,
you can see my muscle
memory won't even let me go
to non-secure--
it automatically upgrades
the traffic for you as well.
So I really highly suggest just
using that right off the bat.
So we go back to
the Cloud Shell.
It's already-- I've been talking
long enough that it works.
And if we refresh
now, it says Hello IO.
So not the most exciting
change that we're doing
live, but I didn't want
to change too much.
But you can get a
little bit of an idea
now about the
end-to-end workflow
of working with App Engine.
And you can take any
idiomatic framework
that you want to work with.
If you're more into
Hapi, or into Fastify,
or just writing something
by hand with Net,
you can deploy anything that's
idiomatic node with App Engine.
So if we head back to
the deck right now,
we had one last
service that we haven't
talked about yet, which
is the one that I'm
most excited about, which
is Cloud Run, the product
that Naomi helped build.
So Naomi, do you want to
tell us a little bit more
about what Cloud Run is?
NAOMI SEYFER: Sure.
Cloud Run-- whereas
in App Engine
you write with your favorite
framework, in Cloud Run
you can include
arbitrary software.
Cloud Run is our serverless
container runtime.
So with containers-- these
are just your normal Docker
containers, for people who
are familiar with that.
You can use any language,
any libraries you want,
any binaries you want if
you have software that comes
prepackaged does a binary.
And you can use the whole
ecosystem of Docker base images
that already exists in
places like Docker Hub.
So you can have an Ubuntu
base image, or even
a Node.js base image.
And Docker containers have
become the industry standard
for software
transmission, basically.
Each Docker container
contains all
that's necessary for
the software on it
to pretend it's running
in its own computer,
though it's not actually.
That's all operating
system fakery
that gives it that impression.
It's much faster than
provisioning a VM.
So the product we have for our
container runtime is Cloud Run.
Container to
production in seconds
while still being
serverless, without having
to provision anything,
or anything like that.
It scales up fast and down to
zero when you're not using it.
And you pay for the exact
usage that you're using.
So we actually have two
versions of Cloud Run.
Cloud Run, fully managed is the
one that we mostly talk about,
but there's also
Cloud Run on GKE.
Cloud Run, fully managed,
Google is your ops team.
Google does all the management
of scaling up and down for you.
It uses our
proprietary back end.
And Cloud Run on GKE
is an alternative form
of Cloud Run that has the exact
same developer experience.
You still use the same
commands to deploy.
It feels the same to deploy.
It still scales up
fast and down to zero.
But it's actually
running on a GKE cluster
that you or your company manage.
So if you have an
ops team that demands
that they have full control over
wherever your stuff is running,
or a platform team that
demands full control,
they can provision a
Cloud Run on GKE cluster.
Your organization
pays for the cluster,
and then you have the same
developer experience for Cloud
Run and it still
feels serverless
to the developers in
your organization.
In Cloud Run, fully managed,
you pay exactly per use
at the 100 millisecond
time scale.
So you rent CPU,
you rent memory,
and you rent request handling.
And then in Cloud
Run on GKE, you
can do basically the same
thing from the perspective
of a development team
within an organization.
You can use the GKE
Usage Metering feature
so that the development
team can get
billed by the operations team
in this same serverless way.
MYLES BORINS: So
when we're talking
about deploying and
building for Cloud Run,
there's a couple of
different ways to do it.
The base is that you
have a Docker image,
and that Docker image
is on GCR, which
is Google Cloud repository.
That's the right
name, right, Naomi?
NAOMI SEYFER: Google
Container Repository.
MYLES BORINS:
I knew I was wrong.
That's why I asked.
So with Cloud Build you
can create those images
automatically
based on Git repos.
You can also do it
yourself with Docker,
build locally and push upstream.
And you can also do that within
your own CI/CD infrastructure.
As long as the image is on
GCR, Google Container Registry,
you'll be able to deploy
it with Cloud Run.
And you may have been asking
what is a Container Registry?
A Container Registry is a place
to store container images,
publicly or privately.
It works via using the
Docker push and pull command.
For GCR, you pay
only for the storage.
So when you push
a container, you
can kind of think
of that container
like a series of tarballs.
You're storing that
inside of a bucket.
You're only getting billed
for the on-disk space
that you're taking up.
One of the great things that
we do offer as well, when
you push containers to
our Container Registry
is that you get container
vulnerability scanning.
So we had mentioned
before that for App Engine
and for Cloud Functions, because
everything from the platform,
such as Node.js or Ruby,
down is managed by Google.
If there's new versions
of Node, or new versions
of the operating
system, or patches
that need to be applied
to system libraries,
we do that all for you under
the hood, and the next time we
spin up your containers
they just have those updates
automatically.
You still need to manage
your own dependencies
within your application.
But when you're
deploying containers,
you've contained everything.
Everything is in
there and you're
maintaining that yourself.
So you're responsible
for making sure
that all that stuff is secure.
That's part of the
spectrum that Naomi
was talking about earlier.
You have more control, but that
comes with more responsibility.
But--
NAOMI SEYFER: We
still got your kernel.
We still got your
kernel in Cloud Run,
but your libraries, you rely
on the vulnerability scanner.
MYLES BORINS: And the
vulnerability scanner
will let if your images
that you have in GCR
have any
vulnerabilities in them.
I'm personally a big
fan of that technology.
So when you want
to go to deploy,
this is the command
that you would run.
And you start with the registry.
And you gcloud beta run deploy,
because the thing is still
in beta.
Image, and then the
link to the registry.
Cloud Run takes that
Container Registry image,
deploys it, and gives you
a URL that you can then
visit to see your
service in production.
And similarly to App Engine, you
can also setup custom domains.
And those custom domains will
have managed SSL for you.
So your whole deployment can
just be gcloud beta run deploy.
And if any of you have any
experience with Cloud Build,
it's fairly intuitive
to set that up
to be automated, based
on pushes to a Git repo,
or all sorts of
other triggers that
can set this off to automate
continuous deployment for you.
NAOMI SEYFER: Cloud
Run is based on Knative
which is a common API
and runtime environment
for serverless containers.
So one of the wonderful
things about Cloud Run
is if you obey the contract
for what a container should
and shouldn't do, you
can port that container
to anywhere that runs Knative.
Now you might have to
dig yourself access holes
to any other Google Cloud
services that you use,
but if you follow the
container contract,
it should be reasonably portable
between Knative deployments.
So Cloud Run is a kind
of Knative deployment,
Cloud Run on GKE.
And Knative is actually
open-source software,
so you can take Knative and
install it on a Kubernetes
cluster of your choice.
The reference implementation
is based on Kubernetes.
Or go to another
Knative cloud provider
and take your same
container and put it there.
So you might have heard
about problems with lock-in
and locking into one cloud.
Cloud Run is what you
might want to choose
if you want to run a
multi-cloud deployment
or not have to
worry about lock-in.
You can actually
take your container
and leave Google with it and
get a very similar environment.
Not only the
runtime environment,
but also the deployment
workflow is both the same.
It uses the same API and the
same runtime environment.
The container runtime
contract that I've mentioned
has a few things in it.
I'm just going to
give some highlights.
This is the Knative
container runtime contract.
The first thing is you need
to make your container have
a stateless service in it.
So if you need a
database, you need
to put that out of your
container and connect to it.
If you need access to
files, you need to put them
in some kind of cloud bucket.
Google Cloud Storage is one
of the possibilities there,
but basically
anywhere on the cloud
that you can store your files.
MYLES BORINS: Naomi, just
a quick question for you.
Statelessness,
isn't that something
we need to worry about all
the time in serverless?
NAOMI SEYFER: It
is something you
need to worry about all
the time in serverless.
Both Functions and App Engine
do require statelessness
in their operation.
The next thing is
whatever your container
is, it needs to listen for
HTTP requests on $PORT.
That's how stuff gets
in, and the response
is how stuff gets out.
If you like a little
thing is in Cloud Run,
mostly that's the same
port all the time.
But if you want to
be able to be porting
from Cloud Run to other
Knative installations,
you want to listen on $PORT
because they might set that
to something else.
And another thing that
you have to worry about
is not using CPU
outside of requests.
You're only guaranteed
to get access to the CPU
while you're answering
your requests.
The system reserves the right
to scale you down at any time
when you're not
answering a request.
There's a few other things about
handling signals and things
like that, and that's
documented with Knative
and with Cloud Run.
You can look that up
on our documentation.
So in our container,
anything Unix goes.
So we decided to just use a
few old school Unix programs
and write a serverless bash
program for handling our 404's.
So we use the Unix
program fortune
to pipe it to the
Unix program cowsay
and serve the results
with the Unix program
netcat and its ncat variety.
Hi, netcat.
All right.
Let's see it.
So over here we're in
the Cloud Run dashboard,
and we have one service
called fortune-telling-cow.
And I'm going to click on
that to take a peek at it.
And it has a lot of revisions.
And very similar to
the App Engine world,
you can see all your revisions.
You can manipulate them.
You can even go to the YAML view
and see the Kubernetes-style
YAML that you have.
That has to do
with a Knative API,
and you can get all
the details there.
So I'm going to go
over to the Cloud Shell
and show how a workflow
might work here
and how our app works.
Here's our repository
here with our serve.sh.
I'm going to increase the
size of this window briefly.
And you can see that
the serve.sh sets
a port if it isn't provided.
But we're going to connect to
the port environment variable.
We trap SIGINT to kill things.
And then what we do is we
start the program ncat,
tell it to listen and keep
listening for more connections
even after the first
one on the port $PORT.
See also the container contract.
And then whenever it gets a
connection, exec the following
things--
echo a beginning of
an HTTP response,
give it a content type
header of plain text,
and then pipe the result
of fortune to cowsay.
And so let's look at what
happens when I run that.
To run that, what I need to do
is I need to do a docker build.
And I'm going to give it a
tag of the image environment
variable.
Ah, right.
Dot.
Oh.
I need to be in the right
directory before I do that.
And I give it the image
environment variable.
And as soon as
this finishes, I'm
going to show you what's in
the image environment variable.
It's not complicated.
It's just where I'm going
to put this thing on GCR.
OK.
So now I want to do docker run
--rm to finish when I'm done.
-it so it's interactive and
gets the terminal, and -p.
And then I want to
map port 8080 to 8080.
And so this is just how
you might run an image.
And now we can see over
in the Cloud Shell,
we can preview this on port 8080
to see what's going on here.
And we have our wonderful
fortune-telling cow.
Kill that window.
Control-C out of this business.
All right.
So in our Cloud Run workflow,
I might want to change this.
Let's say I don't want
a turtle to say this.
I want a different-- or I
don't want a cow to say this.
I want a different kind
of cow, which is turtle.
In terms of cow, say
turtle is a kind of cow.
Who knew?
And I want to save this file.
And now I want to do
another docker build.
That happens very
fast because I'm only
changing the one layer of this
Docker file that I have here.
By the way, let's take a
brief look at the Docker file.
All this Docker file says
it's based on Alpine Linux.
We want to install the
few programs that we use.
Here's the installation of ncat,
the installation of fortune.
We have a more complicated
installation of cowsay
because we're installing
it from a Git repository.
Copy every file from this
directory into the image.
Build a set of
wholesome fortunes,
because we don't want to demo
unwholesome fortunes for you.
Set up our path
environment variable,
and set the command to be
this serve.sh that we viewed.
MYLES BORINS: Fun story.
It was originally
called server, but Naomi
noticed that we
wouldn't be serverless
if we called it server.sh.
NAOMI SEYFER: So
it's just serve.
There is no server involved.
So now that we've built
that Docker container,
we can push it to GCR,
docker push $IMAGE.
So that pushes all of those
layers that we've created.
One of them already exists,
probably the base image.
And as soon as we
get our prompt back,
we can do gcloud
beta run deploy,
and the name of our service
is fortune-telling-cow.
And dash dash image
and our image.
Cool.
Let's deploy that to
our Cloud Run service.
And you see, it tells
you what it's doing,
what it's deploying.
I'm actually in charge
of the command line,
so I'm proud of all
this interactiveness.
It health-checks it before it
migrates any traffic to it.
So if, as soon as you send
any request to your thing
it crashes, it won't
migrate any traffic.
It will let you know
that there's an error.
Cool.
It's deployed and
is serving traffic.
So we can go and
check out this URL.
Fortune telling cow.
Oh, dear.
Did I misspelled turtle?
I'm sorry, -f turtle.
Now I need to docker build
and deploy very quickly.
MYLES BORINS: I think this is
a really great example, though,
of how quick this workflow is.
And for those of you who have
experience with GCF versus App
Engine, it takes
a little bit more
time because all of
its infrastructure
is all being managed by us
at once, but just in the time
that it took me to
stall and talk to you
all just now, we're almost done
deploying this whole service,
upgrading all the
traffic, and rerouting it.
I think it's probably
going to only
be about another 10 seconds.
NAOMI SEYFER: We're
at the health check.
We're routing traffic, assigning
traffic the latest ready
revision.
MYLES BORINS: And we're done.
NAOMI SEYFER: And we're
done, and you should
be able to hit Refresh on this.
MYLES BORINS: Turtle.
NAOMI SEYFER: And it needs
to start up a new instance.
MYLES BORINS: Turtle.
Say it with me.
Turtle.
NAOMI SEYFER: I'm sorry.
We have a turtle.
MYLES BORINS: Turtle!
NAOMI SEYFER: Here we are.
We have a turtle.
[APPLAUSE]
And now if we go and in
our microservices-based app
hit something that
we don't know,
we can see that we have a
turtle instead of the cow
that Myles showed you before.
Now if we can go
back to the slides.
MYLES BORINS: So we've
gone through a handful
of different
serverless offerings
that we have at Google.
We've primarily focused on
our compute offerings, which
are the ones in the center.
So that was Cloud
Functions, App Engine,
and Cloud Run, which is the new,
exciting technology that we've
got.
We also showed some
other technologies
that you may not have the
mental model of thinking
about as serverless,
such as Cloud SQL, which
is being managed by us
and can scale to zero.
Now there is other database
technologies that we have
that we consider serverless.
There's messaging
services such as Pub/Sub,
DevOps services such
as Cloud Scheduler
that I was mentioning
before, which
is basically managed cron.
So if there's
anything that you ever
wanted to do that's
based on a timing,
it just makes it so easy to do.
We have machine
learning APIs as well,
as well as stuff around
Assistant and Chat.
But you can build large
services with all of those.
A really quick summary, though.
Functions, do one thing.
Apps, do many things.
Run, do anything.
And thank you so much.
I'm Myles.
This is Naomi.
If you take a look
at the next slide,
you could see min.kni.sh/src is
a shortlink that will take you
to the Git repo for the project.
Also check out
developers.google.com,
cloud.google.com/serverless.
We're on Twitter and email
and all those things.
Grab us afterwards if
you have questions.
Thank you all so much for
sticking around so late.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]